my heart is pounding so much right feel
my heart feel my heart today I am going
to be designing a hypothetical
engagement ring for Tara I think I know
what you would like your vibe your whole
deal and when you started dating it was
like okay let's move we get a car try
and get rid of me now now every time I
buy her jewelry she loves it that's not
sure so always just get it right no okay
brilliant earth calm create your own
look at all these rings I drop hints all
the time I know she wants a bigger ring
she didn't tell me what shape I'm kind
of like a classic humble gal so she is
very clear with me that she likes yellow
gold no one would be mad about a thicker
diamond she knows you know so he will
ask me what do you like now in the
beginning he just started throwing stuff
out there which I thought was cool so
I'm like oh this nothing the jewelry I
bought her that was rose gold before she
really liked I should stick with that oh
wow that's pretty cool I think Tara will
be able to guess which ring I designed I
also have a feeling she's gonna have
some notes pushing shape looks really
really good really pretty if she doesn't
like it I can just go over all of the
specification she has given me and say
you have to like it
I mean I can probably guess because she
knows I like gold the one I think that's
most me is definitely this gold one here
I'm not revealing a thing wow I love a
lot of sparkle so I would definitely say
this one but it's kind of a hard choice
between those two because that one is
just whoa I think I tear came out of my
eye but for sure I'm gonna say this one
this looks like something Justin would
pick but that doesn't mean I don't want
that okay so I'm second-guessing myself
but I think because I am notorious for
rose gold and it is very dainty and cute
I think this is the one that you
designed for me I think it fits me it's
not for you oh my god looking good I
don't know does it feel right I just
feel like I'm gonna feel so bad and
guilty if I got wrong I love it it's
beautiful and it makes me feel good that
you know my taste pretty well
and excited all at the same time oh my
god I'll be crying I'm glad it was right
yeah yeah it's completely just clustered
with diamonds yeah that's her
personality you know everything about it
just kind of felt like her
it feels very personalized which I like
knowing that it's ethically sourced
every time you look at it you can just
feel comfortable about it right feel
good about the decision so it was
actually pretty simple process not that
I didn't put a lot of effort into it
[Music]